portland now a game and a half behind
memphis san antonio two games behind new
orleans phoenix and sacramento
all in the equation right now
but the blazers bounce back tough loss
to boston on sunday
they get it done as they defeat the
rockets who fall to 42 and 25
and now in a virtual tie with utah
in the western conference standings yeah
look i never thought i'd say this
in a game between these two teams but
that's the most intense game i've seen
in the bubble
all right let's go to the floor jared
greenberg i understand i've got damian
lillard with me you've spoke the last
couple of days about
the desperation your teams needed to
play with must have a
must-win mentality how has that affected
your play over the first three games
here
on the nba campus um just coming out and
competing you know i think
we understand what's on the line and we
know what we got to do to to give
ourselves a chance in the postseason
and that's what we're doing it's not
going to be pretty we've been off for
four months
you know our our rhythm and timing and
playing every other day you know it's
going to take effect
and we just know that we got to compete
we got to be together
we got to warn it more than other teams
when it comes down to it
and i think that's why we've been able
to win two out of these first three
um and almost had a chance to steal one
from boston in our last game but
we hungry and i think our team is
playing like it even when it's not
looking great out there contrasting
styles with
houston going ultra small you guys have
your big guys back tonight
so would you learn about what this style
can do
moving forward um i think you know the
style that they're putting out there
it presents a problem because they got a
lot of shooters and they got
uh two great ball handlers that can that
can score and make plays you know on the
perimeter and james and russ and those
guys out there know what their job is
you know they knocking down shots
when they catch it they open they're
firing and it puts our bigs in a tough
position on the defensive end when
they're trying to protect the paint and
also close out the shooters
but when we know that we got to make
them play on the other end on the
offensive glass
getting our bigs touches in the paint
and i think that came through for us
we've heard so much about game time or
lillard time yeah
but in two of the first three games here
in the nba campus carmelo anthony
has hit massive shots for you guys what
has he meant to the team especially
here in orlando i mean he's a hall of
famer you know i think
it's more disappointing that people are
surprised by it you know i mean he's a
he's a hall of famer like i said
he's a great teammate and that's what we
expect from him
you know we put him in those positions
because we expect him to make those
shots we believe he's going to make
those shots
and we brought him here because he we
knew he would make a difference for our
team and he's been doing that so
um no surprises here we expect that from
him and you know i'm glad that he's here
to come through for us in those big
situations
well damien lillard keeps the blazers
two games back in the lost column of the
eighth spot
in the western conference ayan
appreciate it all right jared thanks
very much
lillard coming alive when they needed it
most carmelo anthony the big shot
late final score here in orlando 110 to
102
the portland trail blazers over the
houston rock